[Music]
and not much change from yesterday
you're going to notice that from
yesterday's 81 degrees today we're
looking to increase about 2 degrees we
will also
have cloud coverage looking to stick
around all the way into that
monday your almanac will show you those
normal conditions should be in the 70s
we will continue to track the 80s for
the next several days
lows for tonight will be up 59 degrees
and you can see that record number of 87
set back in 1988. now let's see what
what is headed in store for the next few
days this ridge of high pressure
will continue to be our dominating
feature that will keep us extremely dry
you can see that today
is day 195 since the last
measurable rainfall for today just
clouds
looking to push through for today into
tomorrow
now mohave county does have a chance to
see some slight chance
of rain for that monday into that
tuesday morning the mountains could see
a 10
chance after that lots of dryness but
there is a weather pattern that's
looking to kick in
for next weekend and that could bring us
some changes you're going to notice wind
speeds staying light
and variable for today very calm
conditions for the next several days so
definitely
enjoy from it here's what's headed for
today
we will track those cooler weather
conditions for the 8 a.m start before we
increase into the 70s
and you can see by noon 78 degrees the
clouds once again
not going anywhere for the next few days
we will see those 80s
83 84 by tuesday
plenty of sunshine for you and if you're
looking for that cooler weather hey
the mountains has it 65 degrees partly
sunny conditions east winds staying 5 to
10 miles per hour
red rock you will be in the 80s for
today and the lakes those highs of 85
degrees lots of sunshine i think boaters
you're definitely going to dig this
forecast north winds staying 5 to 10
miles per hour
laughlin you'll be at 89 degrees for
today's highs if you guys head outdoors
make sure you tweet me at sally j
tv share those weather photos with me
tonight flows 59 degrees partly cloudy
conditions with
calm winds and here's what you can
expect for tomorrow
more clouds those highs of 84 degrees
sunshine and clouds here's your sally
j70 forecast we do track
november pretty consistent for the next
several days
we will see those mid 80s and those lows
in the 50s
back to you